[Musik]
burgschauspielerin dritte schneider
liest ausgewählte rus kommentare
schreibt auf unserer facebookseite
serdar somuncu du bist eine große
schlacht [ __ ]
was hast du gegen unsere präsident
erdogan him kommst du aus armenien oder
was fixie grinsen des manila manila
smiley basar
es ist eine freude wie du dich am
dadaismus der frühen weimarer republik
orientiert und diese kunstform bekommt
ins moderne übersetzt berichten es
selber aus wenn er wieder hier ist als
friedensbotschafter von armenien ist
natürlich viel unterwegs
sie wissen schon wegen des völkermords
der keiner war
details dazu erfahren sie von ihrem
geschichtslehrer hinten links säle 7
[Musik]